well if you're gonna throw a party you
might as well invite everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse
I've been looking forward to this movie
for a while now this is a project that I
was super skeptical of initially just
because it wreaked of Sony's throw
everything spider-man shaped at the wall
and hope to god it turns into money
approach that they've been doing for huh
well they've been trying to do for a
while now and now it's yielding actual
additional films beyond spider-man
itself so like that initially I was way
nervous about the second I saw the first
trailer I was like it looks a little odd
then I saw the second trailer I'm like
okay I'm genuinely intrigued by this and
it's really good it I I may end up
getting into more spoilery stuff I'll
try not to but it's a I'll warn you if I
if I feel I have to go there so this is
you know I don't know how much you know
people have been exposing themselves to
the marketing I've been trying to
minimize it for myself but as the title
would imply there are multiple
spider-man spider characters swinging
around in this film there's six
primarily and despite that despite this
overabundance of Heroes well all with
the same gimmick the film never loses
sight of Miles Morales as the main
character as the heart of the film as
his journey and what he's going through
and you know trying to get a grip on
what's going on to him being the central
thrust of the film it never loses sight
of that which is really really important
because they could have happened very
very easily and it's and miles is great
miles is a terrific teenage character
it's funny I hadn't thought about it
going in but
if I'd thought about it more I would
have been a little bit nervous about
going with miles because since they aged
Peter Parker down you'll back into high
school again for the MCU it actually it
could have been really redundant in
terms of that they did that age of a
spider-man character but this manages to
counteract that for a few reasons the
first is we didn't get to see the Tom
Holland origin so we don't have a direct
one-to-one comparison as far as that's
going in addition to that we do get
version versions of Peter Parker as well
so it feels less necessary to compare
Miles Morales to the Tom Holland version
of Peter Parker specifically because we
have other versions of Peter Parker
actually in the film to compare him to
which kind of takes the curse off that
entire thing plot wise how much do I
want to tell you I mean like look it
looks amazing the actions really cool
the performances are great I love the
music and like this music that in
isolation is not really my bag but it's
super well utilized and it's it's just
fits the vibe of everything going on
that's all great stuff you know it's
it's it feels a lot faster than a than
two hours stick around to the end
especially if you are a long-running
spider-man fan stay through the credits
but as far as plot goes so we get we we
started basically in if you know the
Marvel Comics at all in the Ultimate
Universe it is very much that version
we're dealing with so there is a
spider-man Peter Parker is currently and
already spider-man and you know he's
doing his thing he's in his 20s so he's
dealing with like the be the the big
monstrous version of Green Goblin and
and you know stuff like that there are
there are various signifiers to make it
very clear that if you know your comics
that this is the Ultimate Universe which
is where Miles Morales originates from I
don't know how I know he's in main
continuity Marvel now because
they got rid of the the ultimate
universe I don't know how they accounted
for that how they integrated him but
this is very much sort of taking that
original version miles does get bitten
by a radioactive spider if that sounds
like an insane coincidence it kind of is
but it also like connects to enough
things that I'm like okay yeah cool and
it's not even like a ton of attention
drawn to it it's just like you can
connect the dots yourself girl oh yeah
and he starts getting spider ish powers
and not net and not the same ones I mean
some of the same ones but not all the
same ones that beat up our Kirk lastly
as he gets a couple of new ones and
obviously he's way less experienced in
what the heck it is he is doing villian
wise we've actually got uh quite a few
villains on hand and I don't want to
kind of spoil some of the ones that we
get not that it's like a huge surprise
necessarily but like I I don't want to
ruin Easter eggs for people because it's
fun to spot these folks and and I went
with Liz and she would lean over to me
and go who's that and it felt good to me
like oh well that's this like it just no
that felt nice
but kingpin is financing a bit of Mad
Science with a with a super collider egg
and creating access to parallel
dimensions and that's what takes all of
this off and that's what had that's what
gives us multiple spider people the only
ones I'm gonna draw attention to before
I get into more spoilers stuff are the
ones that I noticed in like even the
first full trailer which is the somewhat
older in his 30s version of Peter Parker
who is the Peter Parker's kind of he's
not in a good place um for for various
reasons and he's I mean he's still very
much spider-man he's not like know I
gave it up it's not it's none of that
nonsense but it's like dude is not it is
a game right now
and then of course also spider-gwen a
Spider Woman officially but like a fans
no or a spider-gwen
and that was uh that was really cool she
she's really well done they're already
talking spinoff either spin-off for her
or main focus on her for the sequel
whatever happens first probably both
knowing Sony but yeah I can see why I
mean it's always been a really cool look
she's you know and she works really well
as a character and because basically
every other spider character in this
knows how to use their skill set or as
miles doesn't it put smiles
simultaneously in a student role but
also in a in a position where like he's
trying to step up but look like he's
just not ready like it's not even a
question of them being judgmental like
even he kind of knows he's not ready but
at the same time he won't he won't just
step back he can't bring himself to do
that I mean there's a lot of great
family dynamics going on his dad is
terrific
and we get his uncle as well his mom
seems realized there's a lot of focus on
his relationship with his dad who's a
cop and as a result doesn't care too
much for spider-man because you know
spider-man is a vigilante so you know
cops are gonna have at best complicated
feelings about somebody like that
and it's just yeah it just looks
phenomenal and if you haven't seen it go
see it if you plan to see it don't watch
the rest of this review until after
you've seen it because I'm gonna start
getting the spoilers cuz yeah I kind of
need to do that so here we go alright so
the other Spider characters that we've
got in this we've got spider-man noir a
voice by Nic Cage which is just fun
we've got spider-ham Peter porker yeah
yeah that's that's there and we've got I
believe it's from the Marvel manga verse
that they did penny Parker who which is
a version I was not familiar with so
this is a young tech genius girl
with a who is like deeply connected to
this experimented on spider and utilizes
the spider to power like a mech suit
it's a little bit weird but one of the
one of the touches is really cool is
that some of these alternate universe
spider people are done in a flat-out
different animation style
spider-ham is very much in the more sort
of Looney Toons s 2d and I don't think
he's actually hand-drawn but he's done
very deliberately to evoke hand-drawn
much more than than the other characters
are spider-man noir is completely in
black and white like they draw attention
to it and make some jokes out of it the
the manga you know penny Parker has the
the stuttered mouth movements that don't
quite match up and again much more
hand-drawn 2d ask look and so that's all
really cool I won't talk about some of
the other villains you've got some that
are just kind of on hand like tombstone
which I spotted I'm like oh cool we got
the Prowler who gets a bit of emphasis
he liked the way he is shot he is
intimidating as heck like I was
impressed how scary they made the
prowler and it feels justified too
because generally when you're seeing the
Prowler you're seeing him through the
eyes of miles into miles this guy is
terrifying and that's before we've been
getting into more of the details of the
character and yeah so that that was
really well done I like and I don't know
if this actually has precedent in the
comics they're their take on Doc Ock I
quite enjoy so it's a woman named Olivia
Octavius so I know that there has been a
woman carrying the mantle of Doctor
Octopus before I think it happened in
the 90s but I don't think they're
specifically precedent for like a gender
swapped alternate universe version of
Otto Octavius which is what this comes
across as is what this feels like so she
might
be semi original in that way but she was
cool I liked her because you know she
was very much sort of the the wild hair
oh you know sort of just tinkering with
tag kind of adorable like yeah I mean
she looked like she looked a little like
professor Trelawney from Harry Potter
and but then you know the the other arms
come out like oh crap and she's oh she's
good in a fight like she's taking on
multiple spider people at the same time
and you believe that they're having a
hard time dealing with her we get a we
get a kind of very highly technical and
like cyborg ish version of the scorpion
which I wasn't familiar with so if he's
pulled from somewhere I'm not too sure
about that like quite possibly the one
and only notable criticism I have of
this movie and it's a nitpick to the
point that like I may even have to do a
separate nitpick rant on it but I'm just
gonna mention it here I don't love the
design on kingpin or actually let me
backtrack I actually do like the design
on kingpin it's a very cool very
stylized very exaggerated design the
problem is I don't think it actually
fits in this universe because since he
is supposed to be part of miles universe
and he's not coming from one of the
alternate ones you know where they can
get away with more exaggerated
proportions he just does not the no one
else is built as exaggerated as he is
and it it's like a brick wall with a
face and it stands out in a way that
like kind of breaks the reality a little
bit but he's voiced by Lea Shriver in in
a much more of kind of a thug you know
like like a almost like a ground level
bruiser worked his way up to the boss
kind of voice which I like I think that
was that was a kind of a cool take on
the guy and he certainly functions very
well as a character but like the design
did it did kind of take me out of it
from time to time but that's kind of my
one and only complaint one and only
issue the action sequences are great
like this the look of this thing is
Gor just it is stunningly beautiful and
I so help me God if the Incredibles two
wins the Oscar over this I'm I don't
know what I'm gonna do but I'm not gonna
be happy because this this is not only a
vastly superior movie this thing just
looks good
it looks really really good like to the
point that apparently Sony's in the
process of trying to patent the
animation process they did on that which
I have kind of mixed feelings about any
sort of entity being able to do that but
I don't know if they'll be granted a
patent on it but look I'm not gonna deny
it looks stunning it looks amazing and
it it's a really really good movie yeah
it it may not be the last movie I see
this year but it was the last movie I
was really excited to see this year and
it did not disappoint not even close
and Liz who is way less familiar with
these characters than I am and didn't
catch all the Easter eggs she came with
me and she liked to do cuz she
immediately loved miles
I think miles is a great hookin even if
you don't know all the minutiae even if
you don't know all the Easter eggs miles
is a wonderful endearing character who
carries the film terrifically so those
are my thoughts on spider-man into the
sprite of Earth have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drops with me down the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons and links and links to page
you're on and a whole bunch of other
things that appeal blah blah blah blah
blah blah
check them out below if you want to if
you don't that's okay too because at the
end of the day folks
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]